now level ins Prime Minister has
announced the government won't repay
foreign currency debt worth over a
billion dollars in a televised speech
Hassan Deb also promised to work on a
plan to protect people's deposits the
default covers a small part of the 91
billion dollars it owes to foreign
creditors Lebanon's debt is more than
170 percent its economic output one of
the heaviest burdens in the world today
we face a huge obligation a debt of 1.2
billion dollars which is due in two days
our conscience mandates we must act with
integrity to protect our national
interest and our people but our hard
currency reserves have reached a
critical low as a result Lebanon is
forced to default the forthcoming march
nine obligation on the euro bond these
funds must be channeled to secure the
basic necessities for the Lebanese
people as a Lakota has more on the
announcement from Beirut the Prime
Minister making it clear that this was
not an easy decision but the decision
had to be taken in the interests of the
country and the people
Hassan tía addressing the nation telling
the Lebanese people that the country the
state doesn't have the money to pay back
its debt the first time in Lebanon's
history it is defaulting on its debt he
mentions the foreign reserves
saying that the foreign reserves of
foreign currency it's dwindling the
country doesn't have enough money to
secure the basic needs of the people
Lebanon needs 10 billion dollars to
import just the basic needs of fuel
medicine wheat so the government has
decided to use whatever money is left
for these basic needs instead of
servicing a debt which he called a
really a heavy burden on the state he
called the situation unprecedented
extraordinary times addressing the
people telling them that in many ways to
expect even more difficult days ahead
telling them that you have resisted in
the past and there's going to be
challenging times ahead this is a
relatively new government he blamed
previous governments but this government
was appointed by the political class
which has been governing this country
for three
decades so not good news in Lebanon's
financial situation really entering a
new phase
Louisa Baker is a professor of economics
at not too damn University in Beirut and
joins me now from the Lebanese capital
good to have you with us on the program
sir I mean was this a default waiting to
happen or could Lebanon have avoided
this well I think you know I really I
never expected to live into such bad
time let's say to read about Lebanon
defaulting you know it's a result of
mismanagement accumulated over decades
and the Prime Minister
really described the situation without
giving solutions obviously he inherited
such a bad situation but still you know
for me to listen or to know that Lebanon
has defaulted it's very tough I think
there are lots of information that
probably should have been more
transparent about for example he said
the reserves or central banks are too
low how low they are a few weeks ago the
governor of central bank said that we
have 30 billion dollars of reserves is
it - is this too low if we had if we
have 30 billion I think we should be
paying the 1.2 million if we have much
less how much do we do how we do have
the speech is a good speech of course
yes it's difficult obviously when you're
when you're listening to it but
therefore if he is sort of being scarce
with the truth and there is now a
default in operation what does that
actually mean for the central bank and
and the financial works or working of
keeping the country financially afloat I
think we will have more problems because
if the default has happened following an
agreement with the creditors probably it
would have been less severe but
seemingly there is no agreement you know
because when Lebanon talks about
restructuring a debt you cannot
restructure anything without creditors
approval seemingly it's you know it's
it's a speech full of ideas and and
there are no concrete steps so far for
example I would have liked to listen
those who have really made Lebanon
defaulting should be responsible you
know those politicians or whatever was
responsible for that bad outcome I think
should be tried or or should be at least
held responsible plus also the central
bank has to be more transparent with us
there are many points in that speech
which really I could not agree to for
example about the size of the banking
sector if it's four times let's say the
GDP or three times what is Terry what is
bad about it - if you want to do some
reforms of the banking system what kind
of reforms you are going to do I am for
mergers but a merger of banks because we
have sixty five banks in Lebanon today
if you want to merge them into 20 banks
maybe the size of the sector would not
go down so what is bothering him about
the size of the sector but the problem
be good and efficient mr. mr. Beck I
think the problem is probably for people
watching is how does this sort of leave
Lebanon financially because obviously if
the prime minister is saying that you
know we need the money to buy the basic
commodities for the Lebanese people
themselves there will be no money you
might say available for infrastructure
or for investment and with the default
comes that sort of psychological problem
on the international front where
creditor where investors don't want to
invest in your country because firstly
they don't know what they're investing
in and secondly they don't know what
they're going to get their return what
return they're going to get and whether
you're true to your word as politicians
and as bureaucrats and it's about that
sort of reputation that is tarnished and
that will upset the Lebanese people on
the surface won't it of course the
Lebanese reputation has been tarnished
you know what I am worried about is not
that the current accreditor are going to
sue us
I am worried about we could not find
future creditors because now is Lebanon
not paying its that many potential
creditors are going to say why should I
lend to Lebanon
if Lebanon doesn't pay plus if I do lend
it I will lend it at a much higher
interest rate which you may will make
the debt even much costlier to us you
know that's why from the beginning I
found the speech empty of solutions full
of description which would be great for
somebody who doesn't know Lebanon at all
you would probably learn about us but
it's I would have expected much more
solution and what is really missing is
the current government how hard it's
going to work now the current government
has been in for two months of course but
hasn't started working on the main files
and I think it's time to go deep into
work and give a solution and work on
solution and this has not started yet
you know the international community is
not going to wait for us until you wake
up I think I probably could say this
current speech is a wake-up call but I
don't see so far the government has
waken up yet well we should see what
does happen in the coming months for the
moment - Louisa Baker thanks for joining
us from Beirut sir thank you thank you
very much